I
gave it to the moon and voodoocan Chigasaki to defeat
you
whencan you do  Hey 50000
yeah yeah
yeah ooooahhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh  It's just that I've been feeling like I'm going to have to buy a book for the day I
can see a new special technique
It's
over5 It
takes a lot of time
to
get off the train even though it's exposed
.  It's easier to save this wooden statue
It's an underground wish dream 8 The strange machine
I'm quietly trying to multiply from this uncle
nan
rar ah ani yeah
It's the
turn of
the intimidating carani that's coming I can't avoid it in this series Wh
Cruz
, I can't freely meet my powers,
please believe me
wh# e 4 rartrue love
camethan  Stop fighting with people and stop moving
Don't be afraid to get in,ifyou'redead, it's
hot at the dawn of the hot water knit
ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah ah genius pon
wa Bach wha and family
taleahahahahahah
ah  It's 4 days tan tanwh Even though I'm
fighting power, there's one more brat Hanu
It's like I can't talk about China
I thought it would be a martial arts
tournament I wonder if there were two wives who survived besides me
and I became a fool who would
stand up against me It's rare, man I didn't expect you to come
rarcatchem
I
'm sorry I'm sorry I'm asking where am I?
I don't think you remember, so
grab hold of the company's small cloisonné If
you get angry, it's
okay parponmere re re If there's a clue in preparation for the battle,
ranrarnore1enmewh
Haa4minutesduhancaramaran
I'm waiting for the finished sharl
I think I have an aura 5
Eh,pleaselisten tothatdqn The
person who saysSarahas betterfightingpowerMovesyou
ware The
name you want to know is uhfar 1st car
Training  You
should have noticed that we're approaching the point of cooperating with each other In front of the
Tama juggling goon, I thought
there would be no hesitation in killing the wind,
hahahaha
Motoryeahheelsday
[music]
[applause]
[  music]
[music]
[applause]
[music]  ]
[music]
[applause]
[  music]